joe musgrove had the no-hitter against
texas in april he's making his ninth
start three wins four losses 2.86 the
era java joe on the mount getting ready
to go rymel tapia will lead off
left-hand batter playing left field for
the rockies this afternoon swinging a
miss and musgrove strikes out tapia to
begin the afternoon
two down here in the first inning and it
brings up charlie blackman
cj crone would be next here's the payoff
pitch the blackman's swinging to mass
came back with that down and in slider
and he strikes out blackman the way he
struck out tapia one two three first for
musgrove with a couple of k's
right-hander chi-chi gonzalez coming off
that excellent start against the reds
seven scoreless innings on thursday and
gave up four hits with a walk rocky's
handled grisham last night
he was over four with a couple of
strikeouts two to one final and ten on a
wild pitch
three two pitches strike three called at
the knees grisham didn't like it but
chi-chi starts off with a punch out
here's manny machado
gonzalez the floridian
to machado and the fastball strike three
call
a pair of cold strike threes for
gonzalez
cj crone came off the injured list
yesterday
run at a lower back strain started at
first went three for four with a double
and scored their only run
it's gotta be a good feeling coming off
the il
that's strike three
crone gets the bad news he threw the bat
was headed down to first base
tripp gibson rings him up that strikeout
number three for joe musgrove that's a
legitimate strike inside part of the
plate
one out in the second inning for ryan
mcmahon
swing and a miss and musgrove got it
going on today
three straight strikeouts he's got four
fernando tatis junior getting ready to
take it at bat for the first time
since mother's day
in san francisco against the giants
scoreless in the bottom of the second
inning and tatis in the cleanup spot for
the first time in his big league career
on the ground up the middle into center
field he's got a base hit in his first
ab back
starts the second with that single to
center
osmer hitting it 305 as he returns to
the lineup today for the padres
3-2 pitch
off again tatis hosmer strikes out throw
down there
and is still in baseball
he did into a split
steal second
then go into a split
brian o'grady will come up brian o'grady
left-handed hitting outfielder the man
gonzalez wants to get to keep the game
tied and he will ground ball to first
grabbed by cj crone to retire the side
no score after two garrett hampson
the rocky's best bunter and good success
at it
that strike three five strikeouts for
joe musgrow
one out here in the third inning and dom
nunez is coming up
the o2 pitch
swing and a miss and muscaro has six
strikeouts
to the first eight hitters of this game
tapia struck out to open the game over
one
so gonzalez leads at second base oh and
two on top yeah here's the pitch from
musgrove and that's looped out towards
shallow center tati's back pedaling he
gets there and he makes the catch kind
of a soft line drive served onto the
outfield grass but fernando does a good
job going back to get it and that's all
for the rockies here in the third inning
they strike out twice more so here's
victor caratini switch-hitting catcher
to bat left-handed against
chichi gonzalez carratini
that average at 247
next pitch grounded up the middle off
the mount backhanded near second by
story turns and throws and safe at first
as the throw pulled crone off the bag
according to the first base umpire nick
marley
well the ball beat him he's still on the
back on the bag that's gonna be it now
and hunter wendell stick gets the word
from new york you are out great great
play
and fernando tatis junior the only padre
to have reached base coming back up
first one of fernando swung on hit in
the air really deep out to right center
field blackman going back looking up
gonna go
welcome back fernando tatis jr
the homers in his first game back again
and the padres take a one-nothing lead
here in the fourth
musgrove
flared a ball into
short right field ryan mcmahon went back
and snagged it
0-1 pitch
hit into the air into
shallow center field hampson on the run
makes a sliding catch
garrett hampson with a big time play
we go to the sixth still one-nothing san
diego picks up jake cronenworth
fly ball right field off the bat at
chronoworth that will
be off the wall the ricochet is nasty
it's by blackman and crowder is going to
run around
he's going to be set around can he come
all the way oh yeah
jake worth wall ball to right touches
the ball and the padres take a
two-nothing lead
run all the bases jake
here's fernando
tatis with a missile over third and down
the left field line heading towards the
corner fernando hits first on his way to
second base helmet flies off standing at
second with a two out double
oh boy fernando all of a sudden three
for three and by the way a triple shy of
the cycle
eric hosmer a strikeout and a fly ball
to left in his first day back from the
covid list 02 pitch to hosmer is
popped up well i'll save that thought
for later on trevor story calls for it
he's got it on the infield dirt at short
but the inside the park homer by
cronenworth makes it two-nothing san
diego after six
man a left-handed batter over two with a
strikeout and a ground out two outs
runner on first
and joel musgrove
trying to get through seven against ryan
mcmahon here's the one-two pitch
swinging a miss got him to chase an
elevated fastball and strikeout number
11 for joe no runs a hit and a man left
seventh inning stretch at petco park
padres a two-nothing lead on colorado so
here's tommy pham to hit for the pitcher
joe musgrove
strike three at the knees so fam is gone
fernando a triple shy of hitting for the
cycle wouldn't that be something and
inside the park
and a cycle on the same day oh yeah
line to left
that's going to end up in the left field
corner
tatis will head for second run scores
padres take a three-nothing lead
that'll work fourth hit of the day for
fernando
two down in the ninth and trevor story
standing in
malanson with the o2 pitch
chopped up over the mound kronerworth
around second padres win